si la réponse de l'armée russe la
contre-offensive ukrainienne de nouveaux
bombardements ici à kharkiv une centrale
thermique un commissariat touche et un
civil tués le kremlin multiplient les
frappes pour tenter de faire oublier ces
images
celle de la débâcle de leurs troupes les
drapeaux russe brûler
ce d'ukraine brandi
car sur le terrain le rapport de force
semblerait s'être inversée deux cent
cinq mille soldats ukrainiens face à 170
mille russe et 6000 kilomètres carrés
récupérer en à peine quinze jours selon
kiev surtout au nord
à ce jour des mesures de stabilisation
été achevés sur plus de 4000 kilomètres
carrés de territoire libéré
certaines sont toujours en cours sur à
peu près le même volume de territoires
libérés
des occupants et des comptes de sabotage
sont découverts des collaborateurs sont
détenus toute la sécurité est rétablie
les soldats ukrainien film les tranchées
construit par leurs ennemis désormais
abandonnée comme inutile
regardez comment ils vivaient il ya
certaines de leurs cartouches des
grenades au ces
et d'après leur image le départ des
russes a été précipitée
ils sont partis ils ont tout laissé
le kremlin lui préfère parler d'un
repositionnement stratégique
mais pour la première fois un allié
proche de poutine le président
tchétchène se permet quelques critiques
boulebda prusse mes erreurs ont été
faites à chum je pense qu'ils vont en
tirer des leçons
dans les rues de moscou la plupart des
habitants se montrent ouvertement
confiant
ils ont dû quitter leurs positions pour
se réorganiser l'unique président
[Musique]
toute façon les ukrainiens vont se
régler de façon anonyme d'autres sont
moins favorables si je vous répondrais
que je dis la vérité je vais aller en
prison
selon l'ambassadeur de france à kiev une
victoire ukrainiennes semblent désormais
possible